this morning Pope Francis is in the
African nation of South Sudan on a trip
that also took him to the Democratic
Republic of Congo the pontiff has been
hearing stories of suffering from people
caught up in years of warfare and before
the trip he discussed a more Progressive
view of sexual orientation that puts him
in opposition to some of his own Bishops
and much of African law Chris livesay
has more
than a million people gathered to see
Pope Francis speak in Kinshasa the
capital of the Democratic Republic of
Congo one of the poorest and most
war-torn countries on Earth
it's enormous passionate crowds like
these that illustrate just how much
power the Pope wields in much of Africa
and if any one person could influence
change it's him
an estimated 10 million people have died
in the last three decades due to armed
conflict much of it over the country's
vast mineral wealth that is not trickled
down to most people here
meeting with survivors Pope Francis said
he was left speechless
a 16 year old boy told of seeing his
father murdered his head tossed in a
basket
a 17 year old girl recounted how she was
kidnapped and raped repeatedly for
nearly two years until she escaped and
gave birth to twins at the foot of a
cross mutilated survivors laid down
symbols of their suffering
your tears are my tears said your pain
is my pain others feeling pain the LGBT
community says activists and radio hosts
scally kepna in some area
lgbtiq people can be can have a violence
physical violence he says a trans woman
was attacked earlier this week by the
police ahead of his Africa trip the
pontiff made headlines when he said it's
not a crime to be gay
but in much of Africa it is like the
Pope's next stop South Sudan here LGBT
people can be thrown in prison with some
of francis's own Bishops supporting the
penalties Francis said such laws are
unjust adding the Catholic Church must
work to put an end to them now that he
set foot in South Sudan the question is
just how hard Francis is willing to push
in a church and a continent where change
has not come easy for CBS Saturday
morning Chris Lindsay Juba South Sudan